and here they are ready for the final
game in the semi-finals
this one will decide who goes to the
final it's going to be momodyarov or
it's going to be
hikaru nakamura hikaru nakamura with a
draw will be in the final
he has to win with the white pieces and
five minutes on the clock
and here we are here we are and it's all
about speed it's
going to be fast it's going to be
furious pieces are going to fly
towards the end of this game for sure
but meanwhile my major of taking a
slower approach
this is a very common tactic in
armageddon chess you just
keep as many pieces on the board and
hope that your extra minute will pay off
towards the end because winning on the
winning on time winning on the clock
is just as viable as winning on position
and slow start
one set of pawns been exchanged both
sides castling what do you think of
anchor
yeah in a way i mean i i do approve of
this strategy i mean i've seen it done
countless of times
and it was very effective you just get a
position
preferably one with an endgame which you
know you can maneuver you can play a lot
a lot of moves
and it will all come down to the clock
and
but we do know that hikaru is a beast
with the clock with the mouse and he's
fantastic with pre-moves
and uh shakurya perhaps not as
strong there yeah he did say shakuriya
just in the last few months he has come
back to
online chess after several years away
he's not as experienced
with this thing with the mouse and it's
all about mouth skills later on if it
gets down to one minute each
nakamura will win if the position is
balanced on the board but right now
white uh mamadyarov he's actually
increased his time advantage look at the
clock one minute and 20 seconds
up on the clock and um white now has the
option of jumping into the center with
his knight he
takes it um nakamura's bishops look good
but the rest of black's position a bit
suspect and he does have to retreat
with his knight it looks like a great
position on the board and the clock for
mahmoud so far yeah i agree with you
they there david um i think this is
really really nice especially because
hikaru has been forced to sound the
retreat and now well
okay it's very very logical play by mama
jaroff
offering to trade of pieces and of
course you can see that hikaru actually
keeps the bishop on i mean was that a
wise choice to keep the bishops
or it would be simplifying the position
just easier to handle
especially with the time deficit yeah
i'm very surprised by
nakamura dropping back with the black
bishop there that black bishop that has
just moved he's blocked in by his own
pawns it's a bad piece
maybe he could have taken it off and
tried to survive the reason white is
better here is because white has a
dominant knight in the center of the
board anchored by a pawn
with the last move white is preparing to
line up both of his rooks on an open
line
on okay also he breaks the pin that
knight was previously paralyzed it
couldn't move because that black bishop
was attacking things now that night
heading into uh more promising squares
and nakamura he's just trying to swap
things off he's playing
ultra solid defensive mode right now but
he had the chance to swap things off and
he he refused to do that but now he's
desperately trying to do that
but i mean i'm just looking at the clock
situation well
the time difference has narrowed and
shakaria has to take
a decision quickly because otherwise
his position will be nothing home to
write about because remember
hikaru has draw odds the game
must finish in a win for shakarya mama
jaroff
he has to go through to the final and i
really don't like what has happened
for mama jaroff over the last couple of
moves white knight the pride and joy of
his position the most beautiful piece in
white's
uh in white's army it's just been traded
off black has
been able to swap that piece and now
look at the clock situation as well
it's about to level itself out and uh
white not only has he been forced to
trade his best piece
no more time advantage nakamura showing
why he is regarded as a speed demon
and now retreating the queen that looks
like the wrong direction for white
yeah and completely the wrong direction
and uh things are certainly going
wrong for mama jarof okay he retreats
his bishop
so he attacks the pawn bishop and the
bishop retreats and now he's being
forced to make a defensive move
on the left in order to blunt the power
of the
black light square bishop but okay
hikari is in his element these moves are
natural you know now he's opening up a
line and
looking at the clock situation while
hikaru is still lower on the clock
and that's something that that shakurya
can actually play on
but okay hikaru he's winning a pawn
black has just won a central pawn with
his knight
nakamura is in full control and uh it
did take him a bit of time but he's
a pawn up not that much lower on the
clock anymore only a few seconds down
this is full retreat mode for mahmoud
he's messed around too much with his
knight too much with it that rook there
pawn out for nakamura this one
is it's getting close already it's
completely winning for black the
position
it's completely slipped through his
fingers and uh okay well
of course the clock is definitely going
to be something that mama jarv can hope
for so i'm expecting him just to make
natural moves he just has to keep
uh now he has to go into hustle mode by
hustle mode i mean start pushing the
black pieces back
um can you do this in a safe way it's
not easy black
brooks both of them were targeting
white's bishop that white bishop had to
be defended
mabajorov stepped forward with his rook
the only thing i can see going wrong for
nakamura is the fact that
the black king is slightly exposed some
pawns have have moved in front of it and
white had a threat there
black's rook stepping back meanwhile
nice
nice blitz type of move you protect all
your pieces
that rook stepping back to a very solid
square and uh
again the time difference keeps
narrowing
now my majority is just under two
minutes but so
has hikaru okay well this is i like i
like this move you know
you're going to lose anyway your
position is worse on the board so why
not just
throw everything into the air and uh
okay the position is liven up
white sacrificed a piece and that was
what you liked ivanka
and now okay white did get two pawns for
the piece and now he's going towards the
black king
things are slowly starting to turn
black's king not entirely safe white's
rook
super active and that's what you need to
do you need to take risks you need to
make your opponent's position
hard to play it doesn't matter about the
objective evaluation
right now black's king looks nice and
safe protected by the bishop but
suddenly
look at the dark square diagonal towards
the black king white needs to get his
queen onto that diagonal and it's almost
checkmate um
nakamura is still in control still doing
fine but suddenly
counter chances for mama yeah and uh i
agree
you know i actually quite like mama
jara's position now especially lots of
practical chances
i really like this philosophy over
protect your weaknesses
and now is it the time to go forward you
have to try
yes you'd absolutely how are you going
to do it are you going to do it with
pawns are you going to perhaps doing it
with pieces
i like what you've done yeah beautiful
beautiful so now
the white work on the right is getting
ready to maneuver itself to attack
the queen and there is now a mouse hole
for the white queen to escape to if she
is attacked
yeah and white does step forward with
his queen there mamadorov he has
upped the pace over the last dozen moves
and look at the kings
white's king is safer than black's king
temporarily at least
um and often that is the deciding factor
when it comes down to these mad
time scrambles when both sides have 30
seconds left on the clock meanwhile
though
nakamura bringing his rook across
threatening to drop that rook down and
attack the white queen
and uh yeah but mama jarvis says no way
and look how he's coordinating all his
pieces so far there is
no active threats and now the advance
finally happens
hikaru under a lot of danger okay but
wow a big mistake by mama jarov he
didn't realize that black's knight was
about to jump forward attacking the
white queen and threatening a fork
white had to give up a rook so now white
is down a whole rook
for only three pawns it's still not game
over still some chances because black's
king is a bit open but
nakamura all he needs to do is trade
rooks and trade queens and the game is
over
mama jarov he has to hope he gets a
trick in to checkmate the black king or
play for time those are the only
remaining hopes black is completely
winning in position right now
and okay white pushing pawns this is
desperation from mahmoud
look at his facial expressions he knows
he's losing um but it's just about
setting that final trap and
he's continuing to advance his pawns
black's bishop did grab a pawn there but
you couldn't take it because white's
bishop was attacked and
nakamura leaning back he knows he's
winning that's his body language when
he's confident
he's getting the queens off the board
he's got 40 seconds that's enough time
to win with an extra rook
mahmoud about to resign there we go
nakamura wins
wow we're going to have a final with
magnus carlsen and
hikaru nakamura for the first time the
american is in a final and the meltwater
champions chess tour